- So wait, what's with
this photo, as well?
Wait, like, explain this one.
- [Joe] What's this one?
- What's happening?
(audience laughs)
- [Joe] Oh, yeah.
- [Kelly] What's happening there?
(audience laughs)
- Well, I got hit in the
face with a baseball bat.
(audience member groans)
- [Kelly] Okay, what?
- When I was a kid.
When I was a kid.
Right around the age of that
Halloween picture, I got.
- How do you accidentally
get hit in the face
with a baseball bat?
Just asking for a mother
of a six year-old son.
- You have to be a really stupid kid,
who's waving a bat
around, that shouldn't be.
- Wow. You're my son.
- And then, yeah...
- Okay, okay.
You're, that's my, yeah.
- I didn't mean to include him in that.
- No, that's actually,
pretty, that tracks.
- Yeah, like, 35 years later,
you're still dealing with it.
So, it's one of those things.
- Wait, so they were,
like your adult teeth
that had already come in?
- Oh yeah.
- So, that's real. So, you
have to wear a little thing in?
- Yeah, these are, this
is a bridge right now,
cause I'm waiting.
They have to drill,
- Cause you go,
- the next screw up, into
my gums, to put the, yeah.
- Yeah, you go from,
like, sexiest man alive,
to, like, Bubba, real quick.
(audience laughs)
It's like, it's awesome. (clapping)
(audience applauding)
It's amazing. I saw that
picture and I was like,
"How is that the same dude?"
(Laughter)
It's amazing what teeth do.
- They really did. Yeah.
- Yeah. It is amazing.
- If I was looking at any
other time in history,
- Yeah.
- It would not be going so
well. Especially the glasses.
(Kelly laughs)
I would be blind.
I'd have no teeth.
- I have glasses.
Yeah, I don't see well, as well, either.